-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You’re here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, the Super Bowl
is just a few days away,
and people are getting
really excited.
Maybe -- Maybe too excited.
A new poll found that a record
68 million Americans
will be making some kind
of bet on the big game.
Yeah, which is tough for me,
'cause I already bet
it wouldn’t go over 60 million.
So...I’m already --
I’m already down.
I knew betting was getting
out of hand this morning,
when my daughter asked me
to put her college fund
in a DraftKings account.
"Don't worry.
I’m gonna double it, alright?"
[ Laughter ]
"Are you smoking?"
"Who are you, the police?"
But actually, I saw
some other interesting polls
about the Super Bowl.
Look at this one here...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's --
Here’s another poll I liked...
Oh.
Larry. Larry.
-Larry, of course.
-And finally...
[ Laughter ]
What?
A deli--
[ Laughs ]
-Wow.
-Wow!
Meanwhile, it’s been crazy
here in New York City
'cause President Biden
has been in town all day.
Yeah, and just one minute
on the subway
was all it took to end
his love of trains.
He’s like, "That’s it.
Good Lord."
Biden had fun
while he was here.
He even took a horse and buggy
around Central Park,
or as he calls it, Uber.
And New Yorkers were actually
very excited for Biden.
It’s rare that we get
to see a president in town
who’s not walking in and out of
a courthouse, don’t you think?
[ Cheers and applause ]
It’s nice to see, refreshing.
But the big story today is that
Republican National Committee
Chairwoman Ronna McDaniel
appears to be stepping down
due to pressure
from former President Trump.
Yeah, McDaniel says she wants
to work someplace more stable,
like Boeing or Twitter.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Apparently, Trump
has been disappointed
with the RNC’s finances.
He was like, "They’re wasting
all their money on my lawyers.
Sad."
Looks like McDaniel
will leave
after the South Carolina
primary.
Nikki Haley heard and was like,
"Hey, want to
split a cab home?"
Yeah, that’s right,
RNC Chairwoman Ronna McDaniel
has told Trump
that she plans to step down.
That’s big news
for the Republican Party.
And based on Trump’s statement,
it’s really affected him.
Here’s what he had to say about
Ronna McDaniel stepping down.
Said...
[ Laughter ]
No, no, no.
No, no.
Ronna McDaniel.
Some more political news.
Last night, House Republicans
tried to impeach
Homeland Security Secretary
Alejandro Mayorkas,
but they didn’t have
enough votes.
If you don’t know Mayorkas,
here he is.
Yeah, well, a lot of lawmakers
spoke out to defend him.
-Really?
-Yeah. For instance,
Congressman Keith Self said...
[ Laughter ]
And Congressman
Brian Mast said...
Then Congressman
Greg Landsman said...
And congressmen Andre Carson,
William Timmons,
and Chip Roy all said...
Congressman Mike Garcia said...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congressman Mike Rogers said...
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Congressman
Chuck Edwards said...
You can see --
At least you see some support.
Some news from overseas.
Today, the Kremlin confirmed
that Tucker Carlson
has interviewed Vladimir Putin.
You can tell the interview
went over well
'cause Tucker is still alive.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently Putin
was a good host.
He was like,
"What would you like to drink?
Tap poison or bottled poison?"
[ Laughter, applause ]
"Which one would you --"
Yep, Tucker Carlson
interviewing Vladimir Putin
may not mean much to you,
but for Trump,
this is like watching OnlyFans.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] This is insane.
[ Normal voice ]
Well, some business news.
I heard that amid low sales,
the head of Fisher-Price
is being replaced.
Yeah.
Even worse, he received
the bad news on this.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
I read that a man
who spent years
building a model
of the Eiffel Tower
with 700,000 matchsticks
has been denied the world record
'cause he used
the wrong kind of matches.
-Aw! Come on.
-That’s what you want to do,
upset a guy
with 700,000 matchsticks?
Burn the city down.
On the bright side,
he did set a record for longest
scream of frustration.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a man in Florida
was arrested
after he showed up
to the airport fully naked
and tried to walk past security.
And since he was detained,
Southwest had to find
another pilot.
We have a great show tonight.
Carey Mulligan is here.
Oscar-nominated Carey Mulligan.
Alan Cumming is joining us.
Ooh, "Traitors."
And we got great music
from Idles.
Stick around.
We're playing a fun new game
when we come back, brand-new.
Come on back, now.